[Music]
what I'm about to tell you is going to
be hard to believe again
I've been pulled through time between
the past and the present and the future
everything is turning
that's right
around
and around we go
all right
again
[Music]
obey
hello
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you Mobius wow great to
see you again
[Applause]
that that's what's been happening wow
time slipping wait times you know that
yeah you've seen that yeah can you fix
that no
it's impossible to time slipping the TVA
I know but we just saw it happen
[Music]
I've been pulled through time between
the past and the present hello
if what I saw is true
[Applause]
this world and after destruction only
one way to find out
good old-fashioned legwork
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is fine
I take a more slow deliberate cerebral
approach
it's really good buy
[Music]
it's out to us
to save this place is this cracked is it
whatever we do
we're playing God
we are gods
all right
but how do you choose
who lives
and who dies
make the hard choice
is on its way
come on you're the god of mischief
always have been
always will be
all over the top don't you think I've
got a spot on
[Music]